this sunday 33 000 runners from around
the world will participate in the 50th
annual new york city marathon two of
those runners share a special bond
forged in tragedy cbs saturday morning
co-host dana jacobson shows us how they
come together to run with purpose
it's going to be
such a wonderful day elon nybrith is
best described by his sister mika in
part as a charismatic music lover he
really appreciated life he was a loyal
person so much so that the 21 year old
was staying in surfside florida a miami
suburb back on june 24th so that he
could attend the funeral of a friend's
father
at around 1 30 that morning the
unthinkable happened
we heard a crash of lightning the
loudest thing i've ever heard
the champlain tower's south condo in
surf side collapsed leaving 98 people
dead
mikko remembers her mom waking her later
that morning
at six in the morning that day she
opened my door and she said the building
elon is then collapsed
when you got to surf side what did you
see
i saw a building in shambles i knew that
they were on the eighth floor
so i just tried to count the floors
and it was just like sand and rubble
it was destruction
in the painstaking days that followed
mika met amnon leibowitz a member of an
israeli defense forces team that
traveled to florida to help with what at
the time was a rescue mission
i just remember his smile
i think
we kind of just clicked we were speaking
the same language you're both engineers
we're both engineers yes we're both i
think very logical and
i think that's how we first started to
bond mika is a chemical engineer amnon
structural i would always come up to him
being like hey if you look at this part
like this is like more vulnerable so
maybe we can address this and so then
you don't have to tumble down the other
building i guess i got into my own head
or i call it productive coping
and he understood that
mika
have a lot of questions and a lot of
idea how to do it better and gave her
time and gave her space and i think from
this moment we become a friend
for more than 20 years amnon a
lieutenant colonel with the israeli
homefront command has been helping with
rescue and recovery missions around the
world is it normal that there are people
that you
find that you just connect with like
that i think this is the first time in
my professional life that i'm talking
with the family i never talk to the
family we try to
totally make
like a wall between the rescuer and the
families because you can't concentrate
and be focused on your work
when you have an emotional thing but
make a is different
it's like
family
their bond forever forged in a moment
where few words were exchanged
hours before mika learned her brother
elon was among the dead i remember
saying hi to him and
you gave me a hug
and i i knew
based on that hug that they had found
him
i didn't have proof but i just knew yeah
and then a couple hours later we got the
call
it was the bond that you already had
yeah
the sign was after
over
12 days we couldn't
say they need to be identified by the
police and so i give her a hug but she
realized something mika and amnon have
built upon that bond with regular calls
and a pact to run the new york city
marathon as a tribute to elon the night
that they found dylan i told him elon
was supposed to run with me my family
was all supposed to be there all is a
hard word for me now did you know right
away that you wanted to run with her
when she told me that elon promised her
to run this marathon and i said i will
run with you i don't think i really
think about it
they've been training together mika from
chicago and amnon from israel exchanging
their stats and keeping each other
accountable i feel like
sometimes you know i'm running i see a
leave fall and i think the building fell
and i go back to the point of time where
i'm thinking how did my brother feel
those five seconds when the building was
falling and i know it's not healthy
but being able to talk about this with
unknown and tell him you know i'm not
having a great day right he gets it
and i think he relates it all back to
the running and says you know you're not
a quitter you're strong
so it gives it definitely gives me that
strength what does it mean
to have somebody who also seems to
genuinely love you and care for you
and cared for your brother even though
he never met him i don't think i could
have done it without him
sorry it's okay
it just means the world i feel like i
have someone watching over my shoulder
[Music]
they're both running in honor of mika's
brother elon but for amnon the mission
extends beyond that part of my running
is the honor for the first responder all
over the world we are very similar
we are leave everything we are willing
to suffer we are willing to sacrifice
and we are willing to go and put
ourselves in danger
to help people it's all a journey you
know in the marathon it is a journey
it's not about finishing but it's like
how you get through each mile at a time
right and so i think it was really that
analog of
life is uncertain you don't know what
the next smile might bring
but you got to take it step by step
[Music]
very wise words on marathon day mika
will be wearing shoelaces from a pair of
running shoes that her brother gave her
so that she can keep him close her
fiance made a tag for the sneakers also
which reads what doesn't kill you makes
you stronger and mika and amnon are
going to be wearing matching shirts they
were designed by amnon's daughter
he's the father of five the oldest is
his only daughter and she's around
mika's age and he told me that was just
another part of their bond that this is
it's a family bond it's like a
father-daughter type of bond and a
friendship obviously but you could feel
it through the zoom even though we
obviously didn't have them together in
person because it's today when they'll
finally be able to see each other again
in person no i feel it through the tv
yeah
what a beautiful human being yes without
a doubt funny no lighter note yeah amnon
is a much faster runner than mika so
they've been training but they plan on
running at the same pace he's slowing
down for her so that they can finish
they each run marathons before no not
her he has he's run a handful of
marathons all right awesome story great
job look at that that video again i
forgot how no i didn't forget actually
one of the worst stories i've ever seen
absolutely devastating look at that
rubble again yeah yeah wonderful piece
well done thank you thank you